christopher m if time travel was
possible would you want to go into the
future or would you like to visit the
past
well anybody would want to go to the
past i think
to uh improve their situation now
right look back to the future too
hey stevo don't jump off that
cliff [ __ ] uh if you can go back
though like
honestly is there anything you would
change that one thing you always
remember like
[ __ ] are there plenty of things that you
would change i would
certainly like to have uh gotten sober
at least
two years sooner right if i if i could
if i could uh
why two years because um i wouldn't want
i'd want to be very careful with the
space time continuum
up until that point and uh
and and and the uh i just really
mismanaged opportunities and
uh i got like um the last two years of
my drinking and using
were really [ __ ] uh
destructive humiliating and um
counter counterproductive so
i mean i i suppose i needed all of that
humiliation
and destruction in order to like be
properly motivated so
i probably wouldn't want to mess with
that either